こんにちは
肇社長です
重大なご報告がございます
私肇社長は
2019年
8月7日をもちまして
日本を飛び立ち
真天つ
ドイツ2 day
活動させていただきます
こんな重大なご報告が
霧綺麗になってしまい本当に申し訳ございませんでした
ドイツに行っても
変わらず元気で頑張ってくださいまあ僕なんかはまだ1カ月であんまりお話とかでき
なかったですけど
ありがとうございました静岡僕たちが何とか
源さんなしでも頑張るので
またこっちに帰ってきた一緒に楽しく撮影したいです
8円も頑張ってください
これ以上
大苦しい空気を出すと
炎上しそうなので早めに
ドッキリということ
ここに
8していていただきたいと思います
ただドイツにしばらく行くというのは
事実であり決して
お前それ関税
っていうわけではございませんドイツに行くことは事実であり
ブーブー
ran うっ
すっつってどういうふうにドイツに行くためを
ためトリオ
ああああああ
ここ1週間げな
シゲ頑張ってい
弦キュッとねこんにちははじめ社長ですというわけで1週間
ドイツに行ってきますおそらくこの動画が出るときは僕もう実行機の中に乗ってもう
ドイツへの向かって空の旅を楽しんでる頃でした桜
ん
うん
n あのん
ん
へと言って期間は一週間なんですけども1週間のため鳥が超使ったです本当に朝から晩
まで動画をひたすら撮りまくってた宝動画を撮っていました
で畑もあるんで畑分も取ったらも1日5本撮影とかをもう3日考えるとあってやって
もう本当にあのユーチューバー史上最強に疲れた
1週間だったなと思いましたまあ数えてドイツに遊びに行くわけでもないんですけど
今回なんでドイツに行くかというとですね遊戯王カードの世界大会がドイツで開催され
ますでもドイツで開催される u 業の世界大会のなんかこうなんだろうレポーター
から公式コメンテーターよくわかるんですけどあこの人の報酬の方と一緒にドイツに
行って
世界レベルの大会を見たり皆さんに友情の良さを伝えていければいいなという感じで
ございますもういいあんまり何処しゃべりしたくないんですけど忙しかったで1週間
動画取れなくなるだけでこんな水ここなる日々が続くのかと思ってくらい大変だったん
でまぁ多分動画にあると思うんですけどもどういってちょっとまたいろんなことできれ
ばいいかなと思って1週間といっ
に入ってまいります
ではん
me
あっはぁ
持ってい
ん